you've aged well Adam going back to the
Jameson you sound like my mom watching
the last ship Steven why can't you be
more like Jordan Jordan calls me every
week so glad to have this next guest on
the program let's get the formalities
out of the way but of course if you
don't know who he is
I mean Full Metal Jacket is where I
first so I'm when I watched it at a
point that was completely
age-inappropriate and of course Chuck
fantastic show sci-fi fans Firefly and
right now the last ship my parents call
and spoil every episode for me before I
get to watch it on Hulu Adam Baldwin
thanks for being with us
oh thanks Steven I appreciate you having
me on I appreciate you at you coming on
it's it's a problem my parents it's one
of the few shows that my parents watch
and I watch but they have cable and I
don't and so everyone just gets ruined
well so they call you up and say ah
Steven Adam kicked ass again yes pretty
much because they also sound like 1920s
paper boys that's how your mom sounds
right
yeah Josh Ravin Adam Baldwin see you
make her sound like a Jameson at the
Daily Bugle but um I like I like Jordan
better that's not far off at all my mom
chiefly prefers my brother no but this
is I'm always we've always talked about
having you on and I just know you're so
busy that it's one of those things right
I don't want to bother you and then I
saw that you were doing every Tom Dick
and Harry's podcast so I said hey hold
on a second I'm a dick now let me call
him a cheap cheap date cheap date
except you're a big man so it assumed
you eat a lot let's talk firstly
everyone knows episode we'll get into
politics last ship was kind of a sleeper
hit wasn't I mean it's it's become
really popular and I know was was it
sort of a slow build because when it
came out it seems like you know a lot of
times in the summer they kind of just
puts
thing in and hope it works it actually
came out of the box strong it was a it
was a great promotional run and and it
was it was a hit from the out of the
gate so I don't know what the hell
you're talking about I don't know what
I've done yeah I but it had it has grown
and now we're in season 2 season 2
always has a natural drop off in any
show yeah but were worse steady as she
goes and we're very hopeful we'll do
season 3 we don't know yet
but we're hopeful the life of an actor
you're always remember even back when
Chuck was going on that was kind of as
well what's what's gonna happen with it
even with the successful shows which is
why I wonder you know when I watch
something like The Walking Dead
they'll write like two seasons out you
know a character that'll come back from
season one the season five and the story
wouldn't be complete without it is that
just sort of a risk you take with with
series like this because I mean you know
in this industry how volatile it can be
even if the show is doing well some guy
cannot well shows shows that are well
put together generally have what we like
to call quote a Bible and in that you
you can have it stretch out over a
five-year period or three-year period so
that they can do that
the other ones that sort of fly by the
seat of their pants can get caught oh
we're getting picked up again crap we
got to write more yeah that happened on
the show that I worked on once with ABC
Family and you could just tell they were
like well that's throwing another love
triangle oh we already did it make it a
lesbian okay the the ultimate the
ultimate in that what I guess would be
Seinfeld just another show about nothing
yeah but it's a fantastic program see it
worked for them because that's kind of
the theme unless you're not a Seinfeld
fan in which case III rescind my comment
and I love I love Curb Your Enthusiasm
too and a lot of conservatives got upset
about it and I've always sort of
contended that hey Larry David is the
ultimate conservative who doesn't
realize it just hates political
correctness he hates people but he
doesn't want to be involved in anyone
else's life doesn't want them involved
with his you know of course he's just a
Holly
leftist by trade but if you watch it the
show it could be written by by any
conservative well this is what I asked
all my my liberal friends of which I
have many how do you actually live your
life as a quote-unquote liberal and
they're they're part press to answer
that question specifically well I care
more than Republicans do i I and then
sort of pin them down or gay marriage
before Obama was for gay marriage or
something yeah I don't know well I
remember I was auditioning actually one
time for it was actually a hosting gig
and at this point someone someone knew
that I was conservative and know at this
point I was already with I had been with
Fox News for very little amount of time
because you know I started off as an
actor comedian long before that and so
it was still kind of in this transition
phase where I was still with my old
agents and they had no idea what to do
with it because all of a sudden I was
working at Fox and I was in there you
know with these hosting gigs they put
you in and kind of circulate you with
other co-hosts and he goes oh so even at
Fox noon as I said yeah he says so like
have you didn't like Huckabee show I
said yeah you know I see no one he's
actually he's not what you'd expect he's
he's a pretty funny guy and this guy
said who's well-known hosts now said Oh
like what's funny about him his views on
gay marriage and I remember this because
at that time I looked him right in the
face and I said you mean the exact same
views as Barack Obama and he didn't know
what to say and of course I couldn't use
that now because he's changed that but
it just goes to show you how quickly
those things change and it's it's not
really based on on what's actually
happening now it's based on emotion well
Huckabee is a bad Christian and Obama
must be for gay marriage even though it
was against it
well he's evolved yes he's evolved into
a super virus oh my god that's like the
last chefs who I did their call back
yeah yeah yeah I thought we're talking
about the last ship you bring me on talk
politics you pinned me down man that's
that's kind of rude it is pretty rude
and you're a bigger man
that I I will say this it's got to be
hard they've must put everyone else on
Apple boxes when they're well at least
quarter apples or half apples do you
know what you know what you know what
1/8 Apple is called right
ok well remember the FCC monitors this
so let's be careful but what is it it's
called pancake I see what you did there
yeah I was expecting something radically
offensive uh oh my god we have to go to
the first break we barely got into
politics Adam Baldwin last ship watch it
if you're not
we'll be right back ladder with Crowder
back with Adam Baldwin I know some of
you are going to get mad why aren't you
talking about politics Oh Adam here's
one thing you're pretty open about this
and I feel like you're one of the few
people who walks the line pretty well I
mean you're an open Christian I don't
feel like I'm letting the cat out of the
bag you post Bible verses on your
Twitter but you've also created some
inroads with with sort of factions that
are pretty I guess historically
anti-christian you you look at gamergate
you look at some of the sort of
libertarian enclaves online and they've
been openly accepting of you do you
think that's because of your consistency
your sort of your cultural influence but
why do you think that is well I think at
first there was resistance to mice my
right-of-center political viewpoints but
when the taking gamergate for example
when they came up against the
authoritarian leftists in their midst
they realized that hey I'd I'd rather be
with this guy than those guys who are
trying to shut me up because I don't I
don't want to shut anybody up I think
more speech is the solution to bad
speech I always have except when I was a
brain-dead liberal back when I was young
but that doesn't matter because I think
because I beat Hall you've evolved we've
all evolved yeah yes but gamergate is
fascinating and I got involved because I
saw something fly through the Twitter
feed and it was a a video post about
some corruption in journalism pegged to
some girl who had had an affair which I
don't really care about that's not that
doesn't rise to the level of the gate
suffix in gamergate gate is everyone's a
gate now Watergate scandal so I thought
well yeah
private private peccadilloes are not a
scandal what is a scandal is what
happened with the gaming journalists and
with the some of the developers and also
the political infusion of of radical
feminism that that came in that the
gamers are like we don't want this crap
at our in our video games leave politics
out of it right so I thought well
gamergate let's see where this goes yeah
and that was a wild ride
why did you brace yourself oh hell no I
don't care
Adam Baldwin has for those of you
listening or watching what we call screw
you money so that changes your point of
view I'm not I'm not I'm not the gamer I
just thought it would be interesting to
see how young people who had not been
exposed to any sort of right thinking
would would react over time and I think
they've become more open the open-minded
ones surely have yes obviously there's
always a closed-minded set that you
cannot reach the true believers you
can't reach but I'd say for the math
vast majority of gamers just want to be
left alone to their games to their
devices they don't want to be preached
to by you know the church of the left so
right I will be remote they revolted the
peasants are revolting miss your majesty
don't don't you dare call me your
majesty I come from Canada where we
still have the Queen and our money and
you're about to cross some lines good
sir um I will say this you know I had
Sargon on and I think I scared him off
of it because I wanted I mean we did
like four hours and we went through
everything and I you know my whole thing
is I hate the whitewashing of
Christianity I hate people who back it
up when they're with a different
audience so I just tried to be
consistent and the people on my channel
we're going oh my gosh I love sorry you
know Sargon is borderline socialist
economically but he's so brilliant when
it comes to cultural issues and I would
say you 90 percent accepting and then
the part we uploaded in his channel you
had so many leftists who claim to be
part of the gamergate crowd going how
could you ever do this guy show I'll
never watch anything you do again and I
thought that reaction was pretty telling
because even though they're more
conservative my audience probably a lot
more Christians probably half
libertarian half conservative none of
them were
why would you have this guy on because
he disagrees with you on half and I'm
hoping that even the leftists who are
sort of taking the red pill so to speak
right now we're seeing wait on a second
not all of my friends are really my
friends here yeah I don't know how you
see that happening but I know you've
been really involved with that and like
I said you see me gain sort of
acceptance I don't know if it's because
you're large and they're physically
afraid of you or or what they I don't
know perhaps my foot in the door was the
fact that I had some cultural cachet
from Firefly and serenity and some other
sci-fi things x-files whatnot but over
time that that that that coin of the
realm only lasts so long you have to be
like you said consistent in your
viewpoints and not back down to the
bullying and believe me there was you
know thousands and thousands of tweets I
don't know if they're from BOTS or from
you know replicants or whatever the hell
they are that were as harassing as you
could you could please but it's like
okay so you're you're harassing me
online and you don't like harassment
great got you you're hypocrites I get it
you're calling me names oh no but I
think over time over time the truth will
the truth will out and you know as a as
a Christian we believe that no he is the
way and the truth and the light and so I
have to I'm gonna have a trigger warning
come up but continue life but I don't
know I got off on a tangent there no
it's it makes it offensive and it's
funny you know I will say this you know
we talked about trigger warnings I I
still do fine that even in dealing with
all these things even just I don't
believe in forcing my beliefs on anyone
or certainly enacting this policy Christ
is kind of the ultimate trigger still is
for the left anything up that still is
the one they're like oh you say it and
they get mad and just flip out yeah but
they they're happy with Muhammad yeah
exactly
well I think it's because thousands of
years later crisis maybe I should say I
shouldn't say happy but they're tolerant
yes they are tolerant of the man who
incurred
throwing of gays off of buildings let me
ask you this I don't think again I don't
want the cat out of the bag but your
your rough around the edges if people
follow you on twitter you know you're no
shrinking violet which is also why I
think I've always had a lot of respect
for you not not to kiss your rear and
I'll get back to dinner meeting you in a
second um I think there's a lot of that
sort of David syndrome where a lot of
people they want their Christians to be
perfect they want him to be these these
sort of smooth stones you know they want
to pumice them down and I remember I
won't say the exact quote but we were
talking and I was feeling pretty down
this is pretty recent you said well
what's what's your prayer like when
you're praying with your wife what you
know what what are you being allowed to
do and you talked about that and yet
some incredible insight and then I was
mentioning some people who were putting
us under attack and you dropped some
bombs like oh those bleep and bleep and
I was sitting there going we just
switched from one to the other and
there's nothing wrong with that because
you're out there on the frontlines and I
don't think a lot of people understand
what it's like to be a Christian in the
public sphere like you are have to reach
those kinds of people you don't get to
be I forgot his name the guy who ended
up being a pedophile
damn it ruined the joke the seventh
heaven father crap and I don't know I
don't you know who I'm talking about the
dad on seventh the pastor you know I'm
saying your rough around the edges but
you're really solid in your beliefs do
you feel like that just sort of comes
with being authentic um in the public
sphere as a Christian I'm really
uncomfortable with that comparison you
dropped in there could you could you
retract that please because that was
weird
yes you are nothing like the pedophile
father from seventh heaven in real life
in the face oh wow well you wouldn't
have brought up Muhammad and
subliminally that brought me to
pedophile and it this is where we ended
up so look I don't know I don't know
everything I am a fallen individual I am
imperfect and I am rough around the
edges as is everyone and those that
claim not to be those that claim to be
perfect are liars right no I've no but I
noticed that and it's tough because you
get it from all sides right I know and
that's what the Founding Fathers knew
and tried to do and and did for well up
until now I guess in enshrine into our
Constitution the fact that we don't want
to be ruled by imperfect
and we want to be ruled by law law that
is determined by the will of the people
the consent of the governed and were
were passed that it seems
mark levin calls it the post
constitutional America it's true it's
sad but true it is we let it and we let
it happen
yep that is absolutely true I mean
conservatives are every bit as much to
blame as the leftists are now and they
still keep making a lot of the same
fatal errors speaking of that you know
I've talked with with larry elder about
this just last week in breadth or we
look at the the Supreme Court ruling
we're not gonna get into the whole gay
thing if to you know dudes want to shack
up but finding something as a human
right that isn't a right in the
Constitution do you believe that it is
outside the realm of possibility or am I
being illogical in saying if they can
find that right and they don't really
recognize a constitutional right in the
Second Amendment they still allow states
to infringe upon that that we could be
one supreme Supreme Court vote away from
really losing access to to firearms you
think that could happen well no I don't
think that'll happen there there will be
attempts at that but no I don't I don't
think I think that's not gonna happen it
would well if it does it's gonna be
messy right well I don't mean they're
gonna say we're gonna ban guns today I'm
going back to your favorite boy voice I
mean you saw the ammo shortage that
happened it's just so easy to manipulate
the firearm market you know kind of like
Smith & Wesson had to put those locks
and their revolvers and it just changed
the whole market there are so many
little things that can happen that could
really create some volatility there
where it would make it near impossible
for the average American but but there
are there are more than enough guns out
there to outnumber the federal
government surely and the state militias
surely and who's gonna comply it's all
about compliance you'd have to have
everyone complying and that just won't
happen and you and you'd also have to
have everyone in the federal government
forces complying with the orders and I
don't think that would happen either
this is not to talk to a lot of law
enforcement friends and and milla
current military former military
Bracey not gonna enforce that they're
not gonna go they're not gonna go door
to door and kick in you know they're the
houses of law-abiding says
they may do it once or twice but after
that the resistance will build and we're
just - they're just too damn many people
it almost sounds like you're suggesting
that an armed populace makes them more
resistant to tyranny I don't want to
misquote you let's just go with that
yeah let's go that's one thing I always
find funny they go Oh what so you think
that a bunch of people they are 15 and
some pistols are gonna fight off the
government with nuclear bombs yeah
that's yeah exactly I owe ya they're
gonna drop bombs on their own
neighborhoods sure and then what but I
had I had a conversation with somebody
on Twitter recently about that whole
thing and I think we got into it I
believe it's Federalists 48 or something
Adams was talking about how were you
know if you haven't I don't have the
exact quotes and it's in really good
language that I don't want to ruin but
he said basically that there there are
too many people - if they're if they're
armed for this this sort of thing and
and the guy he was trying to use the
second amendment the line Ono who was it
was um one of those dumb X talking head
guys his name will come to me in a
second his argument was all the Second
Amendment in a in a organized militia or
whatever the hell it is
and I said I'm yeah it's like the
founders didn't explain what that meant
in other writings did they right it's
it's so clear they're just some things
that are really clear in the
Constitution where say listen I
understand that there's a court to deal
with interpretation of the law and
application but there are some things
that are so I mean you know inalienable
rights shall not be infringed right to
bear arms shall not be infringed can we
can we just find some common ground and
say yeah case closed
of course I come from a place in Canada
were you know in Quebec where we
couldn't even own handguns so the first
time I came to the States and fired one
you know I thought it was I thought I
was snorting cocaine it was like oh my
gosh I can't believe I'm doing this
family rambling rambling back to the
constitutional argument the well let me
I have to go to the break here because
the FCC and then we'll bring you back
and give you the floor Adam Baldwin
large man I want to keep him happy a lot
of with Crowder's
tuned Adam Baldwin is back please don't
hurt me you have the floor sir circling
back to the constitutional argument and
the last two Supreme Court decisions
there's an old saying that where the
Constitution is silent it left to the
states and that's not what happened here
so you have you do have again what levin
calls a judicial tyranny and that's
scary so will people comply as the is
the next question
Rosen how can they force people to
comply well I'm not talking about a
government thing I'm talking about it
could become very difficult to acquire
firearms I think it somebody but I do
think guns are a winning issue I think
the right if I were to advise right now
a GOP guy and you seem to do this too I
think this is a big reason a lot of
people really like you you're a
Christian you're pretty conservative
across the board I mean in a way that's
consistent and but you seem to focus on
winning issues I think right now
feminism has pushed back Islam has
pushed back people are realizing going
alright let's stop the PC stuff here
it's dangerous guns have pushed back
there's too much data and the free
speech thing those four issues are
cultural winning issues do you see it
that way I do and my again my liberal
friends to use the straw man they have
guns they own guns they just don't talk
about them publicly right I mean you
wouldn't know what guns I don't if any I
know you own guns I'm pretty sure you've
talked about guns on Twitter I don't
know how many you own I haven't talked
about owning any really that's
interesting yeah I use sweet now yeah it
doesn't mean I don't doesn't mean I do I
just don't talk about what I have right
well I was asked on Russia today how
many guns do you have I said that is for
nobody else but me to know I did just
tweet out because I got a sweet piece
yesterday and so that was my birthday a
little bit of a brag there because I
have an awesome wife if a wife buys you
a 357 Magnum I think she deserves to be
praised publicly I know sweetheart
happy wife happy life yes exactly and
she's she's all about the guns she's all
about about learning and I'm really
grateful for that I don't know well
again you know talk about gun so that's
fine but a lot of women I'd like I'd
like to come
with you in a 3-gun challenge that'd be
fun yes we can go there let's take it in
that direction um okay so here's here's
another thing you're dealing you just
had it people try and get rid of you
was it Australia at this sci-fi
convention the gamergate people how does
how does that happen how do they get to
the point where they actually try and
stage some kind of do you call that a
boycott what is it called at that point
well at first it was a petition to get
me banned but it failed it was uh just a
few people on Twitter that they know how
they have an algorithm where they can
replicate themselves into you know what
they call bots and right sock sock
puppet accounts and they they generate
you know ten people can generate 5,000
emails to a promoter and at first if the
promoter is not prepared it can catch
them off-guard and should we see this in
other culture cultural issues as well
people get slammed with a bunch of
emails and they react
I mean Bubba Watson I guess is now taken
the Confederate flag off of the General
Lee from Dukes of Hazzard right I think
is an overreaction I think it's not a
reaction yeah the car you can say what
you like about the damn flag love it or
hate it but the car is the car and
you're gonna destroy the value of it by
by defacing it well whether you put an
American flag on it or not is not the
issue I love the American flag I don't
have any issue with with the Confederate
flag it's not my flag I grew up in the
north so I don't have a dog in that in
that hunt and I think a lot of people
are just overreacting because they're
looking to point the finger away from
the over drugged leftist crazy kid who
went nuts and killed people rice it
seems like that's that's the mo of these
mass killers these shooters they're
they're overmedicated youths who you
know get off their meds and go crazy and
they're generally products of public
education and the welfare state when
they're not they're not conservatives
right speaking of not conservative so
you just tweeted this at me so are you
are you a Donald Trump fan or do you
just like how bold he's being I don't
know Donald Trump all I can say all I
can see from what he's doing on the
immigration issue is he's raising the
issue however as they like to say in
artfully the language may be right it's
now it's now part of the national
conversation so that's a good thing I
think it's a good thing too my issue is
people said well you're the only one
who's gonna say it Rick Perry actually
you know my family living in Texas
having spent a lot of time there did a
lot on the immigration issue oh no I
know I like Rick Perry I'm not sure he's
electable I think you know I think
you're right but my point is this with
Donald Trump we did a vetting piece I
don't know if you saw you know he's
given way more to Democrats and
Republicans gave to the Clinton
Foundation both Senate and now he was
for illegal immigration was for
socialized healthcare was for abortion
so I just you know Andrew Breitbart said
he wasn't conservative and I go okay I'm
a little leery but I agree with you that
this is valuable my only issue is when
conservatives sort of throw other
conspirators under the bus and go well
Donald Trump's the only one saying it
when someone like Rick Perry's been
saying it for a long time he's just not
been saying it in a bombastic way and so
he gets overlooked
yeah well that that goes to the gops
lack of media savvy and that's their and
that's their fault it's not Donald
Trump's fault I think you know this very
do I think do I think Trump can be
elected president now do I think that is
his contribution to this conversation is
is worthwhile yes do I think that he's
damaged the GOP brand or can damage the
GOP brand as some of the GOP heirs are
saying look they've done a good enough
job on their own of doing that so that's
true what what does that say about the
GOP brand if Donald Trump can can hurt
it well yeah it's like it's like GOP the
GOP brand if you look at the two faces
of the GOP brand is John Boehner and
Mitch McConnell yeah hello this is true
then until something until until someone
steps up one of these candidates steps
up and I like Carly Fiorina and I like
Marco Rubio
I do want a governor I do tend to have
preference for a governor an executive
to step into that role like Scott Walker
so
would probably be my favorite but at
this point we don't know this is why we
have primaries exactly no and I think
you're right people have given me so
much flak for I've been very critical of
Trump again you know being in New York
working in media without saying so much
some people have different personal
experiences I don't I'm not sold the
guy's conservative I think Donald Trump
is in it for Donald Trump and what I did
write about I wrote a vetting piece as
to the reasons he's not conservative and
then right after that I wrote well here
the top five things Donald Trump brings
to the race and the most important thing
is you know he's willing to poke his
finger in the opponent's chest like rahm
emanuel in the shower and go straight
for the issues and I think that'll
embolden you know look at when he did
the birth certificate thing okay I'm not
a birther I think it's silly all right
hold your emails someone brought up I
knew you know that's not what I'm saying
but along with the birth certificate he
said you know we don't know anything
about his college records we don't know
anything about him and so what happened
was he went full on you know Tropic
Thunder with the birth certificate and
it allowed other Geo peers to say well
you know what he's out of line on that
but he's right and that there is a lack
of transparency and they can sort of
draft in I see that as valuable but I
see him maybe overreaching and yeah I do
think he could damage the party if he
goes too far off the reservation so he
could damage the party in the eyes of
MSNBC in the Washington Post and The New
York Times of everyday Americans I mean
you know people most people if you look
at them who watch like Celebrity
Apprentice I'm you know these numbers
anywhere between 2030 I mean highly
rated show most people didn't like
Donald Trump they think they thought he
was an ass that's not me saying that's
most people anyone who reads his book
will think he's a horrendous person I
mean if you read harder than come back
you just said some really mean spirited
things so my thing is I'm going yeah he
can definitely get in front of the media
but if they can attribute some of the
horrendous things he said to
conservatives I think that could be a
rough a ruffler well they're gonna do
that anyway they're already doing it so
it's dead that bet that horse is out of
the gate you know they hate Nate's out
they hated quote/unquote Simon Cowell
too you know and he's huge huge star
huge manboobs I don't know how that body
type happens
have you met him I haven't I haven't
have you met him no oh okay I thought
you were gonna have a story about like
I've met him and those those things like
speed bags and I thought you got a good
stuff Simon Cowell man-boob story well
listen okay well we'll end the radio
portion here for those listening to rest
really uncensored the next portion here
you can follow it at lot of credit com
last ship watch that uncensored on the
website continued Adam Baldwin we are
off the reservation you can say whatever
you want now there are no no guidelines
here so you make a good point you just
think that you don't think that there's
really any way that Donald Trump could
be a lie more of a liability than people
have already been in the GOP is that
sort of fair to say that's yeah that's
fair and I think it's so early in in the
in the cycle and the experts I've seen
some experts quote-unquote from
Washington you know what their Twitter I
follow them and I respect their opinions
but they think that it's all it's all
starting to happen now and the narrative
is game I don't think most people are
even paying attention you know not gonna
they don't pay attention till next year
I'm looking at your face right now my
skype my god that is a good looking man
let me ask you something unrelated
you've aged well Adam going back to the
Jameson you sounded like my mom watching
the last ship Steven why can't you be
more like Jordan Jordan calls me every
week and I love my she's a great she's
actually been on the show she's
french-canadian and she will say she
would like I would love her in a cabinet
because she would deal with a little
immigration is someone I'd to go through
it legally she would just be like well
you know it was very hard for me to get
my card the people don't even speak
English they Brown people let's send
them back man yeah you have aged well
and here's one thing I have taught I've
talked with my brother about this
full disclosure Jordan knows Adam and
he's
been a good guys um you don't attempt to
look younger than you are so you look
like a good-looking you know sort of
middle-aged older guy you're not going
to fall like judge reinhold Botox and it
was that a conscious decision or did you
just say I can't do anything about it
anyway I'm 53 you know that is I mean it
is what it is
right yeah but you but you're 50 you
look you look in your you know early 50s
but you look a guy who's kept it
together in his early 50s why is it that
so many people your age and
entertainment industry feel like well I
can't be a good-looking 53 year old I'm
53 I've got to try and be a good-looking
32 year old I mean because it's a man
just as much as the women let's not act
like it's sexism in the entertainment
industry I mean look at Roark look at
all of these actors who just you know
they can't even smile for crying out
loud
I don't know John Wayne work - so did it
go it goes back a long way what about
Sinatra come on I didn't know this I
mean it's show business man so why
didn't you like why didn't you get all I
mean maybe you have maybe I'm wrong and
you just have like a really great oh
I've definitely worn wigs
what the hell no any like like you're
not getting that I mean you don't look
like a figurine maybe you're getting
just really good microdermabrasions but
you know like I said you seems like
you're willing to age into you know
you're well I think that's just you know
I mean my mom had good skin and my dad
had good skin so I guess that's just a
genetic thing that's just um that's my
privilege yeah and you're in your clean
living I feel terribly guilty about it I
drink a lot of water actually do you
really drink a lot of water because I
make a lot of water I do drink a lot or
take my vitamins I take vitamin E and I
try to wear sunscreen when I go play
golf you know all that you know
common-sense stuff don't drink too much
alcohol well that's tough to do it your
size I actually you know gage aired my
producer actually if you want to hear
this story gay jared is very little he's
a little man and that's why so many
people you know that's why you can just
look at him and know that he's gay we
went out one night to have a few beers
you know and it was a bunch of like a
brewery tour
and I'm sure you probably have a high
tolerance even though I'm certainly not
assuming you drink a lot Adam you don't
realize probably if you're around
someone of normal size that they can't
handle it gage I remember that you were
you were swimming to the restroom I
don't remember that actually you don't
remember you you got gay Jared blackout
drunk no no no no no we did not
I vaguely remember it I do remember
still in the bathroom a little bit I'll
try to be a guy I was trying to be guys
guys you know you guys all twenties you
got you gotta know your limitations man
you guys know when to start drinking
water I do know them now that is the
benefit that's the that's what we got
from the store that was a lot well we
had one guy who was almost exactly your
size what are you about six six four six
five five okay that's what he was he
played football today means about six
for 245 and I'm six to two and a quarter
and gay Jared is what are you five nine
buck 45 yeah buck fifty yeah buck fifty
so it's a rough night for him if he goes
out with us and we're just having you
know a few beers over the course of the
evening with some Mexican food there's
brick hat just drink half yeah JJ why
don't you think about that drink little
shandies that the ladies drink in
England you know they give them like
little 1/2
ginger ale half beer well see I was
drinking cider so I felt the need to at
least drink the full cider to count as
like half a beer that's just true and
end points are not they're not the same
it'll trade off hundred good cider is
just juice right fine just drink it just
what's what's funny you know a lot of
mass-produced cider and then I'll bring
this back to the culture war Adam a lot
of mass-produced cider is actually apple
juice sort of reconstituted and they
just add an alcohol as opposed to like
real fermented cider cider in the UK was
considered a crusty old man's drink like
the ultimate you know factory worker
from Liverpool would drink cider and
then in the States it was considered a
dainty woman's drink and now it's sort
of come full circle where it's coming
back around do you did you feel like
that's happening in general with you've
been at the forefront with the feminism
thing just masculinity where people are
less ashamed of being men two words
gluten-free
are you gluten-free no have you ever
been gluten-free I am not now nor have I
ever been gluten-free although it does
help some people I've seen it in in
close dear friends and family it does
work for some people
okay well yeah if you have celiac which
is less than 1% of population Earth and
you eat gluten it's not like I think I
have a tummy ache like very sick you
know you're vomiting up your kidney um
it's the only disease though that people
just sort of get to claim like no one's
like I'm just I have a little bit of
AIDS
I'm aids intolerant really Wow you don't
need I mean you didn't need to say that
with that little lilt in your voice well
I was I was imitating a woman who was
gluten free welcome I don't know you
know what you're just attributing your
microaggressions onto me and that's
exactly what gamergate that's what jesse
jackson was talking about your your
trigger and me oh no I wasn't gonna say
anything we're kind of like I said we're
off the reservation on the podcast if
you were to say one thing right now
because you're not like inherently a
political guy you're your cultural guy
who happens to be smart enough to I
guess I've read I've read I'm a soul and
understood him right yes exactly and
when when I didn't know you went when
big Hollywood started before it was
Breitbart sort of the trademark that it
is now I mean it the first site was big
Hollywood and it was you were one of the
first people there I remember Alfonso
ben shapiro and myself i think gary
graham back then yeah how did you come
to know andrew I met him at get together
of a secret organization of which will
remain nameless right and we just struck
up a conversation about life in general
and Hollywood and we became fast friends
he's one of the sweetest nicest most
lovable people you'll ever meet
yeah that is true I am I called him
because I heard him on the Dennis Miller
show and I was like big Hollywood and at
this point I was I had no idea that
there were even any any other sort of
right-leaning people in Hollywood and he
had no
there are a lot there are lots yes they
just they just it's a silent majority I
think do you think it's actually a
majority I do really why I do well
because of the sets that I've been on
and visited and the people that I talk
to and even even the Liberals are
economically conservative they see their
tax dollars there are very few people
who actually walked the walk like an ad
Begley Jr who I can respect I respect
the fact that he he walks his talk so
god bless him I don't agree with him I I
don't think that man is warming the
planet but he believes it any he
composts and he rides his bicycle and
great good for him but the rest of the
folks they see their paychecks I'm
talking about like the rank-and-file
but you see their paychecks every week
and they say where the hell is all this
money going right I'm working I'm
working 60 hours a week and I'm making
the same basically that I was when I was
working 48 hours a week right so he got
kicked up into another tax bracket so
they see that it's really it really
comes down to the cultural divide that
was created back in the 60s through the
70s and all that stuff with abortion and
gay marriage and gay rights those are
the divisive issues for Hollywood
because Hollywood is culturally very
accepting of all different kinds of
people as long as they're good-looking
no but you're not if you're not
good-looking you're what they call a
character actor yeah there's that great
SNL sketch with Tom Brady the sexual
harassment instruction so rule number
one in sexual harassment be handsome
rule number two don't be not handsome
yeah don't be Fred Armisen yeah who is
also brilliant but not Tom Brady no I
used to message him back and forth when
myspace was still a thing and he was
very very nice which is like a you could
just tell was a genuinely kind person of
course leans to the left but I mean we
email back and forth for a long long
time yeah great sketch try to me
interrupt continue with Europe your
Hollywood that's it basically that the
rank and file is center-right or
centrist except on those two
cultural issues do you think that'll
ever change or do you think that'll
always remain that way the culture I was
listening to Ben Shapiro he's on he's on
Morning Show here and he I won't do it
justice on how he described it but
basically he said that the the problem
with Republican Party is that they won't
address each individual person or groups
number one issue and embrace it whereas
the Democrats will take each individual
groups number one it should be at
abortion via taxes via whatever and
they'll embrace and say yep we're on
your side and they'll get that group
whereas the GOP is more like well no we
can agree with you on this but we can't
agree with you on that and though and
though they'll reject the number one
issue for that one group or person and
they'll lose them as voters over one
issue
yeah but Shapiro Shapiro explained it
much much more articulately than that
but that's basically the gist yeah well
my brother out there listens to that
show and actually really likes the
liberal guy in that show he's like they
treat him like crap and he's actually
really funny that's what my brother says
kind of liberal but he's really funny
and they just crap all over him um yeah
not evil like Andrew said not evil just
wrong
yeah my brother's like they treat him
pretty harshly he seems like a decent
guy their stick but Andrew was really
was really good about that too and
Andrews sort of I remember talking about
abortion with them at one point you
realize that there there are arguments
to be made on on both of those cultural
issues that don't need to be faith-based
that don't need to be fire and brimstone
that can be made logically and it's just
not the arguments that the GOP for
whatever reason has picked up yep the
GOP makes a mistake in only embracing it
as a social or religious issue which it
is but it's all but it's mainly a
political issue right and it has to be
addressed that way because you're never
going to get it to zero where there's
zero abortions that are allowed and
you're never going to get it to a
hundred percent so somewhere in between
is the compromise politically where is
that and I guess it's a twenty weeks now
it's creeping downward which is good
right but it'll never it'll never get to
zero so I guess you can see you can dig
your heels in and say if you know be a
hundred percent
I'm totalitarian on that and but you're
not gonna win it right actually I don't
know if you saw Fiorina on the view we
posted that and no one else was really
covering it up to that point people had
kind of posted it and buried it where
she was in the view and she talked about
that and she had two really really good
points one she said well I believe any
feminists should I believe a feminist as
any woman who makes a choice she said a
woman who is CEO of a corporation or who
owns a business who chose to do that
that's a feminist to me to a
stay-at-home mom who chose to do that
that's a feminist to me she said as long
as she has that choice
they had no response they were silent
and then she talked about abortion and
she talked about late term abortion she
said well let's find some common ground
where the majority of Americans are
against late term abortions and they
were dead silent Adam for the entire
interview until she said most Americans
are against late term abortions and
everyone in the view this is what lit
the fire under their ass to get up was
to support late term abortion oh and she
basically responded with listen numbers
boom done case closed people are opposed
to it but that to me is where I think
there's a disconnect between sort of the
James Cameron's the really progressive
leftists who are for late term abortions
and most of like you said the
rank-and-file people even culturally I
don't think you'd find a ton of liberals
across this country who would be for
abortion you know past 22 weeks
am I completely just off my rocker I
think you're right I think that that
knee-jerk reaction no no no comes from
their fear of the slippery slope that
that it will be get that it will get
rolled back to zero right which it won't
that's just irrational to think that
would go all the way back to do much is
I or you may want that you can't get it
so you have to look in live in the real
world and the real world is there's a
compromise at some point and my cutoff
would be okay does does the baby have
yes the baby is life we agree with that
and does the baby have a face fingers
toes brain activity heartbeat then I
think you got you got to look at it on
an ultrasound
and see yep that's a baby so that baby
has to have rights at some point right
and where is that where is that right
it's a medical yeah it's a medical
argument Hitchens even talked about that
and you know certainly not we as a
pulley as a people as a society have to
decide where that is and until we do and
agree on it and have it voted on as they
did in you know in Great Britain they
said they solve the abortion issue via
popular vote and so the people spoke
whereas we had it sort of shoved down
our throats by the the Supreme Court
right which is why which is why it rages
on yeah that's a good point I mean I
there definitely is a sort of a constant
there where when the Supreme Court just
says we're gonna decide and people feel
like they didn't have a chance to hash
it out the issue was never put to bed
right yeah true yeah I mean even you
look at that in California with the
same-sex marriage thing you know it was
people kind of it was I remember being
there with that with that was a
proposition was a prop 8 is that what it
was prop 8 right first it was 22
then it was 8 and it was I was surprised
being in LA and I think people don't
realize how conservative California can
be once you go out of La in San
Francisco and people voted on it and
prop 8 it was voted I remember it was
nowhere near as volatile after prop 8
even though you had the gay rights
activists who were mad it was nowhere
near as volatile as when the court went
back and just overturned it that's when
people got really pissed because they
felt like their voice didn't matter
right yeah exactly and now it's also and
it's also the further away you get from
the locality again the US Constitution
Federal Constitution is silent on the
matter so the states should decide it on
their own
I guess Justice Kennedy and the other
three or four whatever whoever 3
whatever was the four liberals they just
by Fiat said nope we get to decide
that's dangerous now again I'm not Pro
work I don't have any dog in this fight
I live in California it's it's part of
part of the law of the land you know
great fine terrific live your own life I
don't care about people's private lives
or what his name is I care about
judicial tyranny from afar right in
Washington DC that's what that's what
bothers me and if they could do that
what what can't they do that's true and
then I'll leave you with this and the
final issue then because you talked
about that and I've gotten a lot of
emails people who were really mad that I
said I didn't
that wasn't a Confederate flag I'm a
lincoln guy I'm team Lincoln I'm glad
the Union won and yeah me too
right well people got really mad at me
and they go well you don't understand
states rights and that's thing Lincoln
was on the first guys to abuse the
concept of states rights and impose
federal law and I said well hold on I
understand where you're coming from but
states rights don't supersede human
rights are going well whether you liked
it or not slavery at that point was a
constitutionally protected right I have
this email I'm going well you didn't
consult the slave in the matter so I
don't think I'm being inconsistent by
saying yes the federal government needed
to step in to make sure everyone had
unalienable rights that all men were
created equal
before states rights and I can't for the
life of me see how that's inconsistent
but a lot of conservatives have gotten
mad at me and basically say I'm a
statist for being team Lincoln yeah well
they're on the losing side they're not
sure it's the wrong side but it was the
losing side yeah in those are the same
people who say this country is gone I
was surprised at the fourth of July
people go and it's not a great country
anymore I'm going let me guess your
Confederate yeah you conceded the first
war so you're so quick to concede the
war now I guess in roll over yeah but I
think it's it's it's a squirrel that
pointed the flag and this the
Confederate flag is a that's the problem
no no no that's the problem be it was
just a distraction from the real problem
and the real problem is wait the way
children are raised or reported in this
country in that in these huge numbers or
educated by government education right
so that's the biggest obstacle we have
as conservatives is to take back the
schools or the education of our children
right because until that happens you're
just gonna get more liberalism no I
think you're right but I wish people
focused on that to me I was going this
is a perfect opportunity a Confederate
flag just let let Democrats own it
Lincoln Republican you know voting
rights civil rights
Republicans have been on the right side
of every civil rights issue let him own
it Southern Democrats and and what I'm
talking about there was a law a pretty
big conservative contingency who were
not talking about the flag and
businesses running the flag they have
every right to sell the flag everyone
has the right to fly whatever flag they
want but supporting it under the idea
that's that it was states rights to
either enforce slavery or not and that
it didn't need to be federally abolished
and I thought that was such a missed
opportunity for conservatives I mean
it's Lincoln we're not gonna have a
better ambassador right as a
starting-off point that's true another
thing you got to look at is who's
running corporations now and what are
they looking at if they're looking at
social media so you got a lot of young
people in the social media sphere in
corporations that raise these Reds like
oh there's a Twitter Inquisition
we better fold so instead instead of him
saying just don't say anything like
Bubba's Bubba Watson he could have just
not said anything and left the General
Lee in his garage and it would have
blown over and the car would have
maintained its value I don't think he's
gonna paint it over I bet he doesn't do
it yeah I think your brother I don't
think he paints it over either I don't
even think he realized or thought it was
offensive until this all came up no I
think you're right yeah well we're going
to let you go senior Baldwin unless you
everything else you want to add to it
but last ship for people who don't know
where when can they find it and you
should find it folks
it's Sunday nights on TNT Sunday nights
on TNT can you give us any any juicy
teasers for what's coming up juicy
teasers well the crew the Nathan James
has survived the initial apocalypse and
is traveling in and around the Norfolk
area and they run into a group of bad
guys on land that are immune okay okay I
see where this is going I'm seeing a
pattern here with this this virus and
this ship you guys you guys seem to be
survivors and I dig it Adam Baldwin
thank you so much for being on we
appreciate it and keep doing what you're
doing we really do it's it's important
out there seek truth brother Thank You
Senor we will be right back actually we
won't you're on the internet we're in
uncharted territory so just
home if you like this video thank you
subscribe by clicking my face or head
over to louder with glad or calm if you
don't your privilege is showing because
you have access to content of far
greater quality than this and that
offends me